la espera ha terminado tras un año de
retrasos por la pandemia de kobe 19
arranco por fin y formalmente la cob 26
que ha sido considerada como un punto de
inflexión para el futuro de la humanidad
reino unido- recibió de la mano de
chile- la presidencia de esta cumbre la
presidenta de la cop16 por su parte la
ministra chilena para el medio ambiente
de carolina schmidt pidió a los países
del g20 que cumplan con los compromisos
adquiridos
algo que según lo que salió de la cumbre
en roma no parece que vaya a suceder la
esperanza es que se vaya más allá de las
palabras y que se pase a la acción para
mantener vivo el acuerdo de parís y
controlar la temperatura del planeta por
debajo del grado y medio celsius el
presidente de la cope y 6 el británico
alocs arma recordó que la ventana de
oportunidad se está cerrando hemos visto
los devastadores impactos del cambio
climático durante este año sobre todo en
europa en asia y en américa y sabemos lo
que tenemos que hacer esas eran las
palabras y también recordaba que la cop
26 es la mejor y última oportunidad para
mantener la temperatura del planeta
controlada
además dijo que para casaremos juntos o
tendremos éxito unidos mañana más de 120
líderes de todos los rincones del mundo
se reunirán para tratar de alcanzar
acuerdos que se traduzcan por fin en
acciones para por un lado financiar a
los países menos desarrollados para que
puedan mitigar y adaptarse a los efectos
del cambio climático y por otro
presentar planes de reducción de las
emisiones contaminantes que sean mucho
más ambiciosos de lo que hemos
presentado hasta ahora